>> APPROPRIATE THE BRUINS IN
TOWN TO TAKE ON THENAPS IT ON TF
MONTEMBEAU.
GOALS IN RE
BRINGS IT ACROSS.
MIKE REILLY IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
SCREEN.
GETS A GOOD
BOSTON FOR HAULA.
GOOD PLALA
>> PUCK COMES
GOOD DEFENCIVE PLAY BY JEFF
MAKC
STOP.
PETRY AND MARCHAND AS THE PUCK
COMES BAC ARE BACK.
SHOOTS IT.
Applause ]
>> ERIK HAULA OVER.
WHAT A STRANGEACK.
PETRY PENETRATES OUT IN FRONT O.
AND NOW NOSEK WITH A BIT OF
>> COLE CAULFIELD UNABLE TO TIE
HIM UP.
AND C C
COYLE. IT AGAIN.
BATTLING HIM Y
MONTEMBEAU.
MCAVOY READ IT WELL.
EXCELLENT STOP. LAST SECOND.
MCAVOY BEAT HIM.
IT'S 4-1 BRUINS.
>> FACE
COMPLETE.
CANADIENS GET IT BACK.
BACK IT THE SHOT AND
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IN THE WHEEL
HOUSE.
THIS COMES
COLLECTED BY CARLO.
REIL THE SHOULDER
AND SEES SUZUKI.
CHOOSES NOT T GO.
EVANS AT THE HASHMARKS. PUCK.
AND PATRICE BERGERON
BROKEN STICK ON THE PLAY.
GOOD HELP ON THE FACE